después de que su propuesta para subir
los impuestos al combustible terminará
desencadenando el estallido de los
chalecos amarillos hace dos años el
presidente manuel macro me pregunto al
pueblo cuáles son sus sugerencias para
cumplir con las metas en fijadas para
frenar el calentamiento global
cumpliendo con una promesa propia del
mandatario galo se reunió con un grupo
de 150 personas elegidas por sorteo para
que hicieran sus propuestas sobre el
clima
como resultado de macrón buscará que se
añada al artículo 1º de la constitución
la preservación del medio ambiente
constitucional
constitucionalmente primero debe pasar
por la asamblea nacional y luego por el
senado y ser votada en términos iguales
ese día se tramitará como un referéndum
cuando esta propuesta debería ser
aprobada sin problemas en la cámara baja
en donde el partido de macrón tiene el
control pero tendrá más oposición en el
senado entre las medidas que se
presentaron figuran reducir los límites
de velocidad mejorar el aislamiento
térmico de los hogares y que destruir la
naturaleza sea un crimen pero que
francia cumpla con los objetivos del
acuerdo de parís sigue siendo un dolor
de cabeza para el presidente
critica por no haber llegado a la meta
de reducir sus gases de efecto
invernadero mientras que él se defiende
y afirma que el país ha estado lejos de
ese objetivo como consecuencia de la
pandemia